okay what's the latest with the YouTube
advertiser boycott it has been nearly
two weeks since I last talked to you
about this on March 31st we had a new
YouTube advertising algorithm rolled out
by YouTube
the reason supposedly all sorts of ads
were showing up next to racists videos
on YouTube the truth is yes it happened
anecdotally but across billions of hours
of videos watched the truth is that the
YouTube ad algorithm was actually always
too strict not allowing us to make money
on videos that were not hateful or
offensive and this completely shut down
our YouTube ad revenue by 99.9 percent
okay the last update was from April 11th
at that point we were 12 days into the
ad crisis and we were basically making
nothing on YouTube which represents 40
to 50 percent of our revenue crisis
existential threat to the show so then
what happened during vacation April 12th
and 13th we saw a slight uptick in
YouTube ad revenue and I started
thinking Pat we're out of the woods
YouTube is fixing it it's all going to
happen it's going to be fantastic but
then April 14th through the present it
has fallen off a cliff again now for
comparison before the crisis usually for
every 10 videos watched six ads were
shown right so people you know one
person watches 10 videos or two people
watch five four 10 videos six ads were
shown during the vacation we were down
from 60% to 7% of the videos were
showing ads also each video play each ad
play was earning way less than it had
been previously had before before I told
you that we earned about a fifth of a
penny for each ad that played that was
down to about a tenth of a penny so if
you do the math 7% monetization rate
paying half of what it was means we're
at about three and a half percent
revenue it looked as if there was an
uptick but if you delve into the numbers
it's just kind of a facade it lasted two
days and then things crashed again now
one thing that did happen during the
break which was a positive development
is that the New York Times published an
article about how the david pakman show
was being hit
by the YouTube ad boycott the article is
by Amanda Hess it's called how YouTube's
shifting algorithms hurt independent
media has anything come of that well
YouTube is telling us they might have
some good news for a soon but they also
said that the week that we had two days
of a slight recovery and then a total
crash so honestly I don't know at this
point I genuinely don't know if we're
ever going to get the revenue back well
the great article 2 and I think really
will grab a lot of attention to this
issue even though the New York Times is
considered one of the corporate media
outlets it was actually critical of the
corporate setup that we have going on in
the media you know it was well done yeah
very well the Amanda has did a great job
and so in the wake of this we're still
trying to replace that revenue so
there's five really easy ways that you
can help us replace that revenue okay
number one membership you go to david
pakman.com slash membership just get a
membership okay if the prices strike you
as high use the coupon code
I voted 17 patreon we're trying to get
to 2,000 patrons we are about 3/4 of the
way there
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can donate any amount you want just
throw a dollar a month at our patreon
that's all that you need to do to make
up for what we were much more than what
we were making off of an individual
viewer on YouTube number three if you
ever shop on Amazon go to david
pakman.com slash amazon before you shop
for if you have youtube red just watch
our videos we get a cut of your YouTube
red subscription fee and number five get
gear at david pakman.com slash gear so
the good news is the patreon donors are
accumulating this is a cumulative
process I do want your help keeping it
going as of this morning we had what was
the number 1467 patrons so far that's
really great even if you only throw in a
dollar that's a really really good thing
number two good news is that members are
signing up of course to sign up you go
to david pakman.com slash membership you
hit the red hit the red signup button
and then on the second signup page
there's a coupon code and you can use
the coupon code
I voted 17 if you want and last thing I
still plan to do an entire show with my
hair uncontrolled as I published a
picture of to Instagram a couple of
weeks
go if and when we get to 2,000 patrons
Pat I will do a show with my hair like
this no matter what the consequences are
with our broadcast affiliates you know
I'm willing to do some crazy hairstyle
as well really I don't know what it'll
be
yeah I'm not shuffling though would you
dye your hair I think I would just spike
it all up into one cindy-lou who type
thing into a wet you know like the dr.
Seuss character oh okay I was never a
dr. Seuss guy growing up okay I'm sure
that will resonate with many in our
audience
I am foreign so I didn't really have dr.
Seuss understand Argentina